- [Instructor] Here's a very
simplified model of an atom.
The nucleus at the center of the atom
is where the protons and neutrons live,
but they're kind of boring,
because for the most
part they just sit there.
The real star of the show is the electron.
The electron gets to do
all the interesting stuff,
like move around, jump
around, bind with other atoms.
These dashed lines represent
the different energy levels
the electron can have while in the atom.
We like representing these energy levels
with an energy level diagram.
The energy level diagram
gives us a way to show
what energy the electron
has without having to draw
an atom with a bunch of
circles all the time.
Let's say our pretend atom
has electron energy levels
of zero eV, four eV, six eV, and seven eV.
Note that moving left or right
on an energy level diagram
doesn't actually represent
anything meaningful,
so technically there is no x-axis
on an energy level diagram,
but we draw it there anyway
because it makes it look nice.
All that matters is what energy level
or rung on the ladder the electron is at.
Note that the electron for
our hypothetical atom here
can only exist with zero
eV, four, six, or seven eV.
The electron just cannot
exist between energy levels.
It's always got to be right
on one of the energy levels.
Okay, so let's say our electron
starts off on the zero eV energy level.
It's good to note that
the lowest energy level
an electron can have in an atom
is called the ground state.
So how could our electron
get from the ground state
to any of the higher energy levels?
Well, for the electron to
get to a higher energy level,
we've got to give the
electron more energy,
and we know how to give
an electron more energy.
You just shoot light at it.
If a photon of the right
energy can strike an electron,
the electron will absorb
all the photon's energy
and jump to a higher energy level.
The electron in this
ground state needs four eV
to jump to the next energy level.
That means if a photon that
had an energy of four eV
came in and struck the electron,
the electron would absorb
the energy of the photon,
causing the photon to disappear,
and that electron would jump
up to the next energy level.
We call the first energy
level after the ground state
the first excited state.
Once the electron's at
the higher energy level,
it won't stay there long.
Electrons, if given the
chance, will fall towards
the lowest energy level they can.
So our electron will fall
back down to the ground state
and give up four eV of energy.
The way an electron can give up energy
is by emitting a photon.
So after falling back
down to the ground state,
this electron would emit a four eV photon.
Electrons don't have to just jump
one energy level at a time though.
If the electron in our ground state
were to absorb a six eV photon,
the electron could jump all the way up
to the six eV energy level.
Now that the electron's
at a higher energy level,
it's gonna try to fall back
down, but there's a couple ways
it could fall back down in this case.
The electron could fall
down to the ground state
all in one shot, giving up a
six eV photon in the process,
but since the electron started
at the six eV energy level,
it could've also fallen first
to the four eV energy level,
emitting a two eV photon in the process.
It's a two eV photon
because the electron dropped
two electron volts in energy,
and now that the electron's
at the four eV energy level,
it'll fall back down to the ground state,
emitting a four eV photon in the process.
So electrons will sometimes drop
multiple energy levels at a time,
and sometimes they'll choose
to take individual steps,
but regardless, the energy
of the photon is always equal
to the difference in
electron energy levels.
What if our electron's in the ground state
and we send a five eV photon at it?
If the electron were to absorb
all of the energy of the five eV photon,
it would now have five electron volts,
but that's not an allowed energy level,
so the electron can't absorb this photon,
and the photon will pass
straight through the atom.
Keep in mind, the electron in the atom
has to absorb all of the
photon's energy or none of it.
It can't just absorb part of it.
Alright, so now we could figure out
every possible photon
this atom could absorb.
If the electron's in the ground state,
it could absorb a four eV photon,
or a six eV photon, or a seven eV photon.
If the electron's at
the second energy level,
also called the first excited state,
the electron could absorb a two eV photon
or a three eV photon.
And if the electron were
at the third energy level,
or the second excited state,
the electron could absorb a one eV photon.
Those are the only photons that this atom
will be seen to absorb.
2.5eV photons will pass straight through,
five eV photons will
pass straight through,
6.3eV photons will pas straight through.
What this means is that
if you were to shine light
that consisted of all possible wavelengths
through a gas that was
composed of our pretend atoms,
all the wavelengths would
not make it through.
Some of the wavelengths
would get absorbed,
then scattered away in random directions.
This would manifest itself as
dark lines in the spectrum,
missing wavelengths or
missing energy levels
that correspond to the energies of photons
that our electron can absorb.
This is like a fingerprint for an atom,
and it's called that
atom's absorption spectrum.
If you were to ever see this
progression of dark lines
in these exact positions, you would know
that the gas you were
looking at was composed
at least partly of our hypothetical atom.
This also allows astronomers to determine
what stuff in our universe is made out of,
even though we can't get close
enough to collect a sample.
All we have to do is collect light
from a distant star or quasar that shines
through the stuff we're interested in,
then just determine which wavelengths
or energies got taken out.
The details are a little
messier than that,
but this provides astronomers
with maybe the most important
tool at their disposal.
Now the absorption spectrum
are all of the wavelengths
or energies that an atom will absorb
from light that passes through it.
You could also ask about
the emission spectrum.
The emission spectrum are
all of the wavelengths
or energies that an atom will emit
due to electrons falling
down in energy levels.
You could go through all the possibilities
of an electron falling down again,
but you'd realize you're gonna get
the exact same energies
for the emission spectrum
that you got for the absorption spectrum.
So instead of letting
light pass through a gas
composed of your hypothetical atoms,
let's say you made a container
that had the gas of
your hypothetical atoms,
and you ran an electric
current through it,
exciting those electrons
to higher energy levels
and letting them fall back
down to lower energy levels.
This is what happens in neon lights,
or if you're in science
class it's what happens
in gas discharge tubes.
So for the emission
spectrum, instead of seeing
the whole electromagnetic
spectrum with a few lines missing,
you're going to only
see a handful of lines
that correspond to the
energies of those photons
that that atom will emit.
Okay I've gotta be honest about something.
If any physicists are watching this video,
they're cringing because the energies
that electrons will have in
an atom are not positive.
The energies an electron
can have in an atom
are actually all negative values.
This is because the
electron's bound to the atom.
Anything that's bound to something else
will have total energies
that are negative.
This is analogous to a ball
stuck at the bottom of a ditch.
If the ball's not moving
it has no kinetic energy,
and if we assume that ground level
is the H equals zero position,
then this ball's gonna have
a negative gravitational potential energy.
Since this ball has a
negative total energy,
it's stuck and bound to the ditch.
If someone could give
this ball enough energy
so that it would have
positive total energy,
the ball could leave the ditch.
It would not be bound anymore.
So to make our hypothetical
atom a little more realistic,
let's subtract 10eV
from each energy level.
This doesn't really change anything.
In order for the electron to get
from the -10eV ground state to
the -6eV first excited state,
it's still gonna take a four eV photon.
People do get confused with
the negative signs though,
so be careful.
In order to find the energy of the photon
that was absorbed or emitted,
you always take the higher energy level
and subtract from it
the lower energy level.
So in this case, we would take -6eV,
and subtract from it -10eV, which tells us
that it would take a four eV photon
to bump an electron up
to that energy level,
and the electron would
emit a four eV photon
if it dropped back down from that level.
Something else that's unrealistic
about our hypothetical
atom is that real atoms
wouldn't just stop at -3eV
for the highest energy level.
Real atoms have energy
levels that get closer
and closer together as
you approach a zero eV.
What happens when an electron
gets more than zero eV energy?
Well if an electron has
more than zero energy,
that means it's got positive energy.
And if it's got positive energy,
it's not bound to the atom anymore.
It'll be free to leave, it'll be gone,
and we'll say that we've ionized the atom
by removing an electron.
So for example, say the electron started
at the -4eV energy level and
it absorbed a seven eV photon,
that electron would have a total energy
of positive three eV, and so
it would be gone from the atom.
(upbeat music)